hey guys this is dennis the founder take
care and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book in video game guru and this
is our review of the wolverine yes the
long-awaited james mangold directed the
wolverine originally it was a aronofsky
house I remember when aronofsky was
first uh there I was like oh aronofsky's
one of my favorite directors so go
direct the NOAA Noah's Ark ass so what
James Mangold he's a director I like I
don't love him but I like his stuff he
you know he's done a walk the line night
and day which a lot of people didn't
like but I enjoyed it he's just done a
lot of things what he's good in this
with walking line he's good at character
moments and I think this is where this
where the Wolverine shined this is
interesting just to kinda I guess look
look on it like when I was watching I'm
like man this doesn't really feel like
an x-men movie I almost felt like to
beat a comic book term like a one-shot
like you go to the story go tom
bookstore you get a one-issue just kind
of standalone story I mean it is you
know comes from Frank Miller loosely
based on Frank Miller chris claremont
yeah story back in the day of wolverine
going to japan and it's so cool because
like this felt like this is gonna be
like a regular it's like a good action
movie like the reason it wasn't trying
because i think the problem with Marvel
it's not marvel studios we know this is
Fox you know this is marvel but it's Fox
and like their that's their x-men 3
there that whole stuff means less is
messed up i mean their timeline there oh
yeah he's gone I mean the comic book
stuff is gone basically so what this did
is I think it kind of backed off of that
and just said okay we're gonna tell a
nice simple Wolverine story with him
going on an adventure and that's all it
was I thought it worked and that's
that's why I liked it yeah I mean that's
why I liked it it was it was much more
focused on on will the character a
Wolverine of Logan and I feel like Hugh
Jackman was at his best as that
character I think in this movie you get
to see who Wolverine is more so than any
of the x-men movies including I mean
that you know the not-so-good x-men
origins wolverine yeah yeah like this
one was something like I felt like oh ok
that's where he's coming from as a
character ya know he's I mean he does a
great job he looked great he's as big as
he's ever been I mean he was yo I mean
think it's he's huge and thing has he
been doing for 13 years it's 2013 x-men
was about 2,000 I think I've
2001 give or take 13 years he's been
doing this character and he's he still
brings a so it gives it as all when he's
doing it I've always a there's a
weakness in the x-men franchise has
never been Hugh Jackman's performance
yeah or his willingness to work at the
role it's just I like that they took a
step back this movie wasn't perfect by
any means no solid actually I like that
it was set in Japan I like that most of
the main cast was Japanese I mean you
had the yet Viper and femke chance and
kept popping up and then you know I see
that the previews and then also you know
he Jackman of course but I mean I liked
it was a mostly Japanese cast it felt
authentic that one which is great yeah
and also I mean other like those small
criticisms I have of it it towards the
end it kind of felt a little more like
application yeah more generic x-men type
of thing ameralik yeah like the ending
and I was a little disappointed that the
ninja scene wasn't longer like I thought
there was gonna be more action there so
I was a little disappointed that some to
the movie had a budget but it didn't
feel big budget no I don't go too far
encima Jason Bourne but it did feel it
felt small it for like a small kind of
clothes like a lot of intimate scenes
out of you know from the two Japanese
leaves the women they you know they were
great i mean it was just it felt like a
small intimate movie yeah i mean his
relationship with the Mariko yeah young
girl dread yeah yeah so I like those
relationships I mean I don't know if the
the romantic relationship work that well
but the the kind of maybe the
relationship on the friendship part of
it worked worked a lot better right I
mean the thing is with would always been
run the difficulty and I think
mainstream America doesn't really care
about this but I know comic book fans
and people that i'm not a huge xmen
family of people that are huge x-men fan
terms of the books is you know whatever
i want see the Dark Phoenix saga and
they think that's kind of ruin everybody
wants to see you know days of future
past we know is coming and we know that
you know it's supposed to be kitty price
must be kind of the head of that story
but we know it's going to be huge ack
yeah because it's not I mean this is the
nature of Hollywood it's like in comic
books you can have kitty pryde as the
main character and movies you need
somebody to sell this 200 million dollar
movie so it's going to be Hugh Jackman
ladies love them like from our moms too
yeah
I mean everybody likes you Jackman so
he's not gonna be ellen page as kitty is
kitty purr like Ellen Page but she's not
gonna sell 100 million dollar movies now
ya know so no but I like this departure
I think it was a good thing i liked a
lot of the character moments i liked you
know most of the action was pretty
pretty good maybe you know not all of it
was the best but yeah I i also agree
with you where it didn't actually feel
that big budget no i don't know what the
budget wasn't feel big like if it was
like 100 million under i wouldn't be
surprised it didn't you maybe even not
even 100 million maybe I don't feel like
that I don't know what it is who knows
but it did it felt small I called us see
a lot of scenes like just conversations
like over dinner like in a you know how
somewhere it wasn't I mean the biggest
set i mean i guess you seen other
previews is that that train seems pretty
big but it's not like avengers big or
spider-man there's no big like bridge
falling down and what I like though this
is everybody a lot of people being
complaining that all these superhero
movies all these big blockbuster movies
like everybody's destroying the city hey
the world's under attack this was small
there was no world ending I mean you
know there was some scientific stuff
going on when the world wasn't in danger
and they weren't destroying Tokyo Tokyo
doesn't destroyed in this movie yeah and
uh I I didn't care for the Viper
character female I felt like she was out
of place cuz in this he kind of had Hugh
Jackman you know as Logan Wolverine okay
that's he's like the the mutant with the
superpowers you had the girl she kind of
had a little superpowers but not really
yeah I mean when she thought it was her
normal fighter you know but everyone
else was normal and so I didn't like
this inclusion of this Viper character
in there where everyone else was pretty
it was pretty normal you know you it's
kind of like that the heroes complex if
you guys ever watch the TV show heroes
what ended up happening the first season
was pretty good where you you felt like
all these are special people and they
live these normal lives and they have to
kind of like hide their powers or even
when they use them they're special yeah
and then later he rose was like
everybody's you know everyone's got
superpowers everyone can do end right
yeah and so that's what I liked about
this Wolverine movie was that it wasn't
for the most part i mean the even the
main ninja guy who's just a good ninja
but he wasn't nothing superpower about
him i mean i think it's too with the
lady who is i think your name is
svetlana something like I didn't know
anything about her going as I go here's
just tall pretty blonde let's sushi and
then but the thing is the problem i had
with others i could tell she was forcing
an axe and i didn't know who she was so
I looked her up and he's from Russia
which is fine lady what she was had her
user regular accent because I could it
was really it was noticeable I kept here
in try to force an American accent I
would have been found with her Russian
accent her native tongue like that's
fine but yeah a bit of a discharge I
thought she was kind of weak yeah I just
didn't really care for her character at
all right yeah but overall there's
actually a lot of good like comedy bits
to in the movie there's some funny parts
and I would say this is a pg-13 movie
but it cuts it really close to our yeah
like really close like they're swearing
there's blood there's a lot of act like
they're that he's the one effort they
can yeah like there's it takes it right
up to like what r-rated movie what
should be in some living books are I
mean they don't know only thing missing
is there's no like blood gushing yeah a
little spray I think that's what
aronofsky want to do and ask you want to
take it all the way to an R but I was
like no we need more money yeah less
money uh yeah so yeah and Oh make sure
to stay tuned after there's a host
mid-credits scene that everyone loved
some people like it more than the entire
movie so that's just a hint I liked it a
lot you know I like the movie a lot you
know besides besides its flaws um
overall I'd say yeah I'm gonna give it a
b-plus yeah it's one of the the better
summer movies of this season and yeah I
recommend it what about you i did i give
it a be plus i think you know as much as
I enjoyed Man of Steel I liked how this
movie what I wanted me to seal the deal
was kind of slow down yes and just stop
and tell a story I think that's what the
Wolverine did it slowed down it wasn't
super fast paced i kinda so don't have
to hold this kind of intimate story of
this superhero and i really appreciated
that yeah there's a lot of character
moments that I felt like man of steel
was missing because I've heard
complaints about Wolverine like oh it's
boring it's like well only if you want
like tons of action
Man of Steel then yeah I guess you're
right but this was like yeah the moments
between her him and mariko and yo kyo
and yoshida i care about the characters
yeah there's a whole backstory it gets a
little convoluted at the end but leading
up to it you know i liked it i enjoyed
it so yeah that's what we thought of the
wolverine you can post your comments
below on the website think caricom and
on our youtube channel make sure you
subscribe it's a think hero pro you also
come find us on twitter i'm at griffin
de and i'm at think hero and you can
also check out our facebook page that's
a facebook.com slash think your fans